are you doing sir
i'm good man how are you doing good to
see you nice to see you so in a fire
which of those guitars are you saving
first
oh man that's a good question uh well
only two of them are mine and i think i
gotta go with this one
uh that's a nice collection it's a
little different than what i have behind
me a little bit
just just a touch uh so let me start by
saying i thought the card counter was
great uh you guys uh paul made such a
good movie um what was it about the
script that said i gotta do this
um well i mean i think it was even more
than the script you know i think the the
thematically what the movie's exploring
is really exciting um you know about
guilt and past trauma and how we cope
with past trauma and move forward
and uh i i think it's all it's all you
know um
playing beneath this this poker
aesthetic which is really exciting and
clever the way that he translates poker
terms into you know real narrative
action terms i thought that was really
fun so i mean i knew the movie was
clever i mean paul schrader is obviously
you know a living legend and and uh so
that was exciting i i worked with oscar
once before um so he's a super cool dude
and great actor and
um yeah i was just excited about a lot
of things really
you share a lot of scenes obviously with
oscar and he does so much in this movie
by doing so little what is it like
playing across from him in some of those
scenes um if you don't mind talking
about that
yeah no i think it's i'm glad you you
noted it um yeah i think he's that's i
mean it's one thing that uh he does
really well you know it's just kind of
this unspoken
uh dialogue and uh i think that there's
there's a lot of that you know in the
dynamic between us and um
you know he's a very very mysterious
character you know and it's a slow burn
to revealing who this guy is and what
his past is and
and uh yeah i think it was just a fun a
fun dynamic to to explore you know most
mostly there's that tension from what
they've both been through in their past
and this mutual understanding
in that and so i think that's what we
were kind of playing on top of
what surprised you obviously paul's
worked with so many people what what
surprised you about working with him on
set that maybe you weren't expecting
i think his um
he's super charismatic and
he is
uh very economical in his style
and in the sense that he's only going to
do two takes two or three takes at most
and if he feels something
you know from from the actor she's just
going to move on so you got to be ready
to you know give it your all and you
know nail it on the first couple takes
or else you might just move on you know
um and i think that you know uh also he
would do things like on on the first day
we were shooting this scene by the pool
and
we had some rain coming in so we had to
do the wide shot anyway it but then he
did a couple setups where he would just
start in the middle of the scene he just
wanted us to start in the middle of the
scene and i'd never done that
with
any other director before where you you
know you didn't get any run up it was
just like you'd start on
this line because he's oh because he
knows he's only gonna be in that shot
for the
the later half of the scene
and so it was just interesting to kind
of get you know you know understand what
his style was like
and uh to to
to uh to reckon with it and just you see
you had you know you had to be on your
toes which was fun
is it is that mustache from the tender
bar
oh no no it's uh just my
laziness pure laziness
yeah
yeah
well this is gonna say i gotta go but i
was curious about clooney's tender bar
oh yeah i mean we we finished the film
earlier this year it was a
really good time uh we were shooting the
height of a pandemic so you know there
was that but we had as much fun as we
possibly could
uh cannot wait hey listen i gotta go
they're gonna kick me out great to see
you man and congratulations thank you
appreciate it